[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGEI SOKOLENKO:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
My name is Sergei Sokolenko.
I am the product manager
for Cloud Dataflow.
And today we'll be talking
about advancing serverless
data processing
in Cloud Dataflow,
introducing distributed shuffle.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
We have Googlers standing
by ready to answer them.
Let's get started.
I want to spend just a few
minutes talking about Cloud
Dataflow and what it does.
We are an industry leading
platform for serverless stream
and batch data processing.
Customers use us because
we provide unified batch
and steaming data
processing capabilities.
And we offer them in a
serverless, fully managed way
so that customers
don't have to worry
about managing infrastructure.
We have an open-source
program model.
It's called Apache Beam.
And customers also
enjoy the ability
to use us when they only
have maybe a few records
per second streams and
ranging up to millions
of queries per second.
When the team went
ahead and thought
about how to better
improve Cloud Dataflow
and simplify the data processing
challenges that our customers
faced, we realized we needed
to re-architecture our data
processing
infrastructure actually,
the way that the industry
is doing data processing.
And to explain why we
needed this re-architecture,
let me tell you a quick story.
How did the industry solve
the problem of processing
really large data sets?
So imagine it's the year 2000
and you have 1 petabyte of data
that you want to process.
Well, who am I kidding?
In the year 2000 a
terabyte size data set
would be considered
really large.
So what do you do if
it's the year 2000
and we have 1 terabyte
of data to process?
You'd probably use a large
mainframe or a Unix box.
Remember, it's the year 2000.
And you would use SAN,
or Storage Area Network
storage that was attached
to this big mainframe.
As time progressed and new
technologies became available,
for example,
MapReduce, you would
switch to a cluster
of cheap Linux nodes
where storage was
actually part of the box.
And then as things
moved to the cloud,
you would still use your cheap
Linux infrastructure for a CPU,
but you would switch to
network attached storage.
In 2010, Google
published a Dremel paper
which introduced a novel
concept of processing
large volumes of data by using
distributed storage and compute
clusters.
And in 2011, they launched
BigQuery, our flagship data
warehouse that was based
on the Dremel concept.
BigQuery had a replicated
and distributed storage.
It also had a highly
available compute cluster.
But it also had something
that the original Dremel
paper didn't mention.
And that's the distributed
in-memory shuffle
tier that connected both
storage and compute.
So the question becomes,
why did BigQuery
introduce this
distributed shuffle tier?
What was it that caused them
to care so much about Shuffle?
Well, let's answer the question
first, what is Shuffle?
Imagine you have a
very large data set,
and it's a key
value base data set.
So you have key value pairs.
If the data set is reasonably
sized or small in size,
you can probably group
and join this data set
by sorting it, and
doing it in memory,
either on this box, the single
box that you have, or on disk.
Now, if your data
set is actually
exceeding the capacity of
a single processing node,
you have to distribute
the processing and sorting
over multiple processing nodes.
And then it becomes tricky.
What you want to
basically end up
having is a sorted
set of your data
by key, where keys are assigned
to particular processing nodes,
and all the records
related to these keys
are co-located on the
same physical machine.
And in the process
of sorting, you're
going to be ending in
a Shuffle operation
where records are physically
moved from the boxes they don't
belong to to locations
where they belong to,
basically sorted by key.
And this is what a
Shuffle process does.
Now, BigQuery processes
large volumes of data,
and it does it in
a distributed way.
So it made sense for them to
optimize the Shuffle step,
because, as you
can imagine, it's
such a resource intensive
and time intensive step.
In Cloud Dataflow,
in my product,
we have very similar needs.
And our customers have
very similar challenges.
They want to group
and join data,
and we're dealing
with large data sets.
And so we have to deal with
it in a distributed way.
In Dataflow we ask
ourselves the question--
can we apply similar
concepts of a distributed
Shuffle to our own pipelines?
I wanted to walk you through the
life of a batch Cloud Dataflow
pipeline as you submit it
to the Dataflow service.
What happens when you actually
send this job to our service?
On the left hand side I have
the graph of the Cloud Dataflow,
a Cloud Dataflow pipeline.
It's what we call a
directed acyclical graph,
with stages and edges
connecting these stages,
as data flows from
top to bottom.
On the right hand side, I have
a more simplified representation
of this graph.
We have data sources.
We have data transformations.
These are the green boxes.
They can be either filtering,
or projections, segregations.
We also have join and
group by operations.
And we have data sinks into
which we write results.
So what happens if you submit
this job to the Cloud Dataflow
service?
Well, first off, we
are going to create
a cluster of processing nodes.
And then we're going to start
reading from data sources.
And as we read the
information or data elements
from data sources, we're
going to start applying
data transformations on them.
We're going to be doing the
filterings, the projections,
the aggregations.
Once we hit the joins
and the group bys,
we're going to initiate
a Shuffle operation
and use persistent disk
volumes that are attached
to your processing nodes.
Now, at the end, we are going
to write into our data sinks
and shut down this
processing cluster.
In Dataflow, as I
said before, we're
dealing with large
volumes of data.
And very similarly
to BigQuery, we
wanted to optimize
the interactions
between our compute
and storage facilities.
So we introduced recently a
separate distributed in-memory
Shuffle component in Dataflow,
and made it completely
transparent to users.
As a user, you continue
writing your pipelines,
and you don't think
about whether you
want to do Shuffle
in a distributed
way or any other way.
You just specify a
parameter that you
want to use a Dataflow
Shuffle component.
And we'll take care from there.
Let me explain the
architecture of our service.
Our user code is still running
on the compute cluster.
And this compute
cluster is connected
through a very large and
fast petabyte network
to the Dataflow
Shuffle component.
The Dataflow Shuffle is deployed
in multiple GCP regions,
taking care of
regional availability.
In the regions where we
don't have Shuffle deployed,
you can still do
Shuffle operations.
You are just going to be using
the persistent disk Shuffle
operations available today.
But in the regions
where we are deployed,
we have several components which
take care of the Shuffle job.
First off, we have the auto
zone placement component.
This component is
responsible for picking
the regional zone in which
to run your Shuffle job.
It will pick the zone based
on the available capacity
and closeness to your
data sources and sinks.
Now, once the zone is
picked, the Shuffle proxy
will start interacting
with the code that is
part of your Dataflow pipeline.
And as part of this
interaction, the Shuffle proxy
will accept the data set
that you want to shuffle,
and then either pick the
in-memory file system,
if your data set fits
entirely into memory,
or it will partially
distribute data
between the in-memory and
the on-disk file system
if the data set is too large
to fit into memory entirely.
This is all transparent
to users or developers.
They don't have to
decide how much data
is going to be shuffled on disk,
versus how much data is going
to be shuffled in memory.
We take care of
all the processing.
One benefit of this approach
is that many customers
are reporting they are seeing
performance improvements
from this re-architecture.
So if in the past a pipeline
that used persistent disk
shuffle might have
taken you 45, 50 minutes
to process a certain data
set, and if after some
tuning and using SSD
persistent disks,
you might have reduced this time
down to, perhaps, 20 minutes.
With Dataflow Shuffle
the processing time
of such a pipeline is
now closer to 10 minutes.
The results will not apply
uniformly to every pipeline
in production.
But these are approximate
performance improvements
that we are hearing from
a lot of our customers.
Another benefit of
Dataflow Shuffle
is that we are now able to
scale to much larger data sets.
In the past with persistent
disk based shuffle
you were able perhaps
to shuffle maybe
a 50 terabyte large data set.
And the reason why 50 terabytes
was kind of the magic number
was because after that
volume the interactions
between your processing nodes,
the physical reshuffling
of data elements,
the coordination
between the workers
was just too much.
With the migration to the
Dataflow Shuffle service
you're now able to shuffle
much larger data sets.
Customers are reporting that
they are routinely shuffling
100 terabytes and larger.
And the ceiling gets
larger and larger
with every monthly
release of the service.
So at this point I
wanted to show you
a demo in which I will
quickly join two data sets.
They're pretty large data sets.
In total, they constitute
100 terabytes worth of data.
My pipeline is
relatively simple.
I have two inputs.
They are GCS buckets.
And each of these
buckets, it's actually
a single bucket
that contains 50,000
files, 1 gigabyte in size each.
And I'm going to explain what
the contents of these files
are very shortly.
So these inputs are being
joined in my pipeline.
And I write the outputs,
which is a join result set,
the result set of a join,
again, into GCS buckets.
On the right hand side you
see the code of my pipeline.
I used Scala to
develop this pipeline.
And I also relied on a
package developed by one
of our customers, Spotify.
This package is
called [INAUDIBLE]..
It makes it really easy
to write pipelines.
I'll quickly explain what
happens in this script.
If you focus on
the main function,
I'm defining my left
and right inputs.
That's my input
one and input two.
I'm then doing a left
outer join of one
of the inputs with
the other input.
And I am saving the results
of this left outer join
into a collection of files.
Each of the files in my input
bucket has three colons.
Remember, each file
is 1 gigabyte large.
And I have 50,000 files
a gigabyte in size.
So each of these files
has three columns.
The first column represents
the key, by which
I will be joining my data sets.
The second column is
a sequential number
that just iterates through the
records located in my input
file.
And then the third
column is the payload.
And if I had a
production pipeline,
I would perhaps have a
serialized representation
of a business object here,
perhaps a sales transaction,
or a user clicking on a web
page, anything that makes sense
to your business.
So with this, let me
switch to demo mode
and show you how easy it is to
initiate a Dataflow job that
runs and uses Dataflow Shuffle
to shuffle a really large data
set.
In Shell I've done
some prep work.
And I've already uploaded all
the files in my input bucket.
I wanted to show you the
command I'll be using
to initiate the Dataflow job.
This command is using
the Scala build tool
to run this particular
class file, the demo.join.
And I am specifying a
few parameters here.
First off, I'm going to
tell the project in which I
want to run this job.
I also specify to
the Scala build tool
that I want to use my
Dataflow runner, meaning
I want the job to be executed
in the Dataflow service.
I'm specifying my inputs.
And the inputs is
actually a Shell variable
which will result
in a filter, kind
of in a pattern
that specifies about
50 terabytes worth of files.
And lastly, I have
a command that
specifies my Shuffle operation.
So if you wanted to know
how to launch a Shuffle job,
what you need to know is, just
specify an experiment flag,
and the flag says Shuffle
mode equals service.
That's all you need to
do to run a Shuffle job.
And incidentally, I also
started the job just
by playing around
with the parameters.
That's all good.
In a few seconds you
will see the results
of this job submission.
Hopefully it will be a success.
It usually takes between
15 to 30 seconds just
to send the files
back to the service.
Before the demo I've
done some similar runs
of 100 terabytes in size.
So let me show you the
results of the jobs
that I ran just before the demo.
Here's the collection
of the Dataflow jobs
that I ran previously.
And let me pick one.
And by the way
already, my job is now
being run by the service.
But it's obviously not finished.
So let me still explore
one of the previous jobs.
It has been
successfully executed.
Everything is green here.
You'll recognize
the pipeline graph.
It takes two inputs
and produces an output.
Now, just to show you how many
data elements this pipeline
crunches through, I
have 50 billion rows,
which will be joined from
each side of the join.
So both the right and
the left side of the join
will have 50 billion rows
of 50 terabytes in size.
The actual join
operation happens in what
we call a call group by key.
This particular joint will
create 100 billion groups
of the same key.
And then the result
of my join will
be persisted in a GCS bucket.
So it will actually be a
collection, a large collection,
probably tens of
thousands of files.
And it will be almost
half a petabyte in size--
2.5 trillion records and
half a petabyte of data.
So this entire join took
me only 7 and 1/2 hours
to run the day before.
And during this execution
I was able to rely
on Dataflow's distributed
processing capabilities
by using 1,000 workers to
run my joining, my reading
from sources, my joining, and
my output into destinations.
Here's a pipeline graph
of the worker history
that shows how many workers
we used during the execution
of this job.
After a quick spike
to 1,000 workers,
Dataflow maintained the
number of workers at 1,000.
The 1,000 here is a
kind of a magic number
related to my project.
My quota is limited
to 1,000 workers.
And so this is why
Dataflow didn't go above.
So for about seven
to eight hours
1,000 workers were crunching
through these petabytes of data
and produced 2.5
trillion output records.
Similar to this
100 terabyte run,
I also did several similar runs,
but just different in size.
And I've plotted the
graph that represents
the duration of these
runs in relation
to the size of the joins.
So my 100 terabyte
run is all the way
up there in the
upper right corner.
And I also have
two additional runs
which differ from my 100
terabyte run in size.
And I always step down like
by 5X reduction in size.
So the 20 terabyte join
ran for about 100 minutes.
And the 4 terabyte run ran for
probably less than 20 minutes.
As you can see, Dataflow is
able to scale the execution
time of my joins
pretty narrowly,
depending on the
data set size, which
is a great quality of this
particular Shuffle permutation.
Usually Shuffle starts
getting slower and slower,
and becomes non-linear when
you increase the data size.
The other good quality
of Dataflow Shuffle
is that the resources used
for the shuffling of this data
set also scales linearly.
You don't see it
in the graph here.
But if you can reproduce the
results in your own tests,
you would see that the Shuffle
resources also scaled linearly.
So so far we've talked
about batch pipelines
and how we do shuffles
in batch jobs.
Dataflow provides the unified
batch and streaming processing
environment.
And you might ask
yourself, how does this
apply to the streaming
pipeline as well?
Do streaming pipelines also
need to be able to do shuffle?
The answer is yes.
Just like in batch, streaming
pipelines can also do groupings
and joins.
You can group and join streams.
Or you can group and join
streams and static snapshots.
And this leads to a need to
have a distributed streaming
shuffle.
Very similar
arguments apply here,
as we just discussed
in the batch case.
In streaming there's also
another consideration
which is very important.
And that's the state of
your time window storage.
Now, I'm going to explain
what time windows are,
and why we need to store data
elements related to these time
windows.
But just suffice to say to know
that in streaming customers
typically want to
aggregate data elements
based on some time dimension,
some business time dimension.
And we need to accumulate
the data elements related
to individual time windows
in this time dimension
until we can actually
process them.
Let's take a minute to review
the life of a streaming
pipeline similarly to how we
looked at the life of a batch
pipeline.
I have a pipeline that
leads from Pub/Sub,
does a windowing operation
basically, windows my input
stream by some business
time dimension,
then does a grouping
of data elements,
and runs an aggregation
operation account in this case.
It basically counts the
number of elements in a group
and stores the
results in BigQuery.
So let's focus on the group by.
One thing to remember is,
in a steaming pipeline
once you submit the job
to the Dataflow service,
we will divide the streaming job
into three phases, everything
before the group by,
everything after the group by,
and then we will have
the group by operation
which will be implemented
as a streaming shuffle.
Data flow deals with very
large volumes of data.
And the way we deal with
these huge volumes of data
is by parallelizing work
and doing the processing
on many, many workers.
The way the parallelize work
is by dividing our input data
sets.
Kind of sharding the data inputs
by key, dividing them by key,
and then assigning key
ranges to individual workers.
So these key ranges become the
basic unit of scaling for us.
And we only assign
and distribute
work between processing nodes
by assigning key ranges.
And these key ranges become
owned by a particular data
processing worker.
You might ask, where
do we take the keys?
If your streaming pipeline
has a group by key operation,
we'll take the key that you
specified during the group
by key.
If you don't have
a group by key,
we'll actually auto generate
keys and then partition them
into key ranges.
So let's take a look
what happens when
you start your streaming job.
First off, we'll create
a processing cluster
of streaming workers.
We'll assign the keys to
each individual worker.
As you see here, the keys of
the before-shuffle operation
and the keys of the
after-shuffle operation
are being assigned
to different workers.
And some workers might
get more work than others.
Well, they're going to
store the keys and the data
records associated with these
keys on persistent disks.
This is how we currently
do streaming shuffle.
All of the information,
very similar
to our current implementation
of batch shuffle
before the Shuffle service.
We are using persistent
disk volumes in both cases.
And when we have to scale
our streaming pipeline,
when, for example, we start
with five processing workers,
but realize that our
data volume justifies
the increase of this cluster
to, perhaps, 10 processing
workers, what we're
going to do is
we're going to start
shuffling the disks that
store the key ranges that
contain the data records.
So the entire data
disk, the entire PD disk
will be assigned from
one worker to another.
And our streaming
autoscaling implementation
works very well for many cases.
But as you can
imagine, there is a lot
of shuffling of disks going on.
And it might not be the
fastest way to reassign work
between processing workers.
Another thing to remember
is that the number of disks
used in a current
implementation of Shuffle
in a streaming pipeline, that
number of disks is fixed.
And it's determent at the
beginning of the pipeline.
We typically pick a
very reasonable number
at the beginning.
But then we never
change the number
of disks for the duration
of the streaming pipeline.
The only way for us to give more
disks to a particular worker
is basically by taking
an existing disk
from another worker.
So we just covered how we
do group bys and shuffle
in streaming.
Let's also look at the
windowing operation,
because it's quite central
to the concept of a streaming
pipeline.
To understand what
happens during windowing,
let's quickly review what
a data stream represents.
Typically customers have two
important time dimensions
in their data streams.
The first important
time dimension
is the business time
of the transaction.
We call it the event time.
It typically represents
some business timestamp.
If you have a sales application,
when was the sale done?
Was it 8:00 AM, 9:00
AM, some other time?
If you have a
marketing application,
when did the customer
interact with your website?
So it's the click time.
The other interesting
dimension in data processing
is the processing time.
So this is the time when your
data element actually arrives
at your processing pipeline.
And interestingly, event
time and processing time
will always differ for
pretty much every data
element in your stream.
And here is why.
I have an example of three
business transactions
that all happened at
the same business time.
So the sale happened at 8:00 AM.
My green, my blue, and
my yellow data element,
they all happened
at the same time.
Now, they actually arrived
at different time points
in my streaming pipeline.
You might ask yourself, why?
For example, if the sale
happened on a mobile device,
that mobile device might
have had different bandwidth
capabilities.
And so as the
record was traveling
through the networking
infrastructure,
it took its time and got
delayed by almost an hour.
Perhaps another
customer, the customer
who submitted the
yellow transaction,
was on a plane at that time.
And so there was
no connectivity.
And the sale
transaction actually
didn't get into a network and
into your steaming pipeline
up until three hours later
after it actually happened.
So this is why event time
and processing time differs.
But users actually don't want
to deal with processing time.
This is not what their
business represents.
They want to be able to
deal with event time.
take the input stream.
And they would like to be able
to divide it into nice windows
based on the event
time, and then
run aggregation operations
based on time windows defined
on event time.
So now that we understand
how windowing works,
let's kind of
conclude and explain
how we store these data
elements until we can actually
do anything on them.
Because there's a difference
between event time
and processing time, we're
going to have to cache
and store temporarily
data elements related
to time windows.
And we are storing them,
again, on persistent disks,
just similar to how
we store Shuffle data.
So the persistent disk volumes
have two functions here.
They will store
your Shuffle data.
And they will store temporarily
the time window data,
up until the time when we see
that no other records related
to a time window arrive, and
we can trigger our processing
on these time windows.
The Dataflow Streaming
Engine is our implementation
of Dataflow Shuffle, but
in streaming pipelines.
Very similarly to batch use
cases, we have asked ourselves,
can we improve the processing
of Shuffle in streaming cases?
And can we improve the window
state storage for streaming?
The Streaming Engine moves
the processing of state,
as well as of Shuffle from
the processing workers,
all the way to our
back end service.
And in the process,
users get three benefits.
First off, they gain
smoother autoscaling.
We don't have to move around
persistent disks anymore.
The other benefit is, we can
now do much better maintenance
of our operations.
We don't have to shut
down user pipelines.
We can maintain our
back end infrastructure
without impacting customers.
And lastly, the user code that
still runs on the processing
nodes, we are not
moving that one.
So your user pipeline
still runs on a cluster
of processing nodes.
Your code gets more resources
because the operations
that used to run, the
system operations that
used to run on the
same processing node,
have been moved to
a back end service.
And now, suddenly,
your user code
gets more memory and more CPU.
Let me give you an example of
how autoscaling was improved
with the Streaming Engine.
I have a stream of
data that I collected
over a period of one hour.
And that stream ranged from 1
to 10 million bytes per second.
And I have two distinct spikes,
increases in this data stream,
somewhere closer to the first
third of the time period,
and then at the end
of the time period.
When I launched the job, a
streaming job, a streaming
pipeline without using
the Streaming Engine,
I got the following graph
of the number of workers
that the Dataflow
service decided
to use to process my data.
As you would expect,
the number of workers
initially was quite low.
I think it was about three.
But then as the data increased,
and as Dataflow service
realized that the
backlog was growing
and we could have
used more resources,
Dataflow has increased
the number of workers
all the way to 15, and
kept it at that number
until the intensity
of my data stream
declined and we didn't need
that many resources anymore.
All the way up until
the end of the pipeline,
or the end of the hour,
when the stream rate,
again, increased, and we
needed more resources.
Now, compare this graph with
a graph of a steaming pipeline
with the Streaming Engine.
The first thing
you'll see will be
that the number of streaming
workers that the Dataflow
service will launch
at the first spike
is going to be smaller
than in the previous graph.
And I'm actually going
to overlay the two graphs
so that you see it
a little bit better.
So Dataflow didn't
need as many workers
to process your data, because
now your system operation,
such as Shuffle
and state storage
are running on the
back end service.
Your user code gets
more resources.
It has a better throughput rate.
The other thing that you
will see from this graph
is that we are now able
to much quicker downsize
the number of workers used
in a streaming pipeline.
We didn't need to wait all the
way until we saw the reduction
in the data stream.
So just to summarize, let me
wrap up and transition to,
and try to answer a few
questions that some of you
submitted online.
The Dataflow team has learned
that using a distributed
shuffle was really the
key component, a really
architectural decision for an
effective separation of state
storage and compute processing.
We did this in the
batch pipelines.
We offered this capability
in streaming pipelines.
In batch we offer it
in Dataflow Shuffle.
And it allows your
batch pipelines
to run faster and scale
to larger data sets.
In the streaming case, we
have the Streaming Engine,
which also leads to
improvements in autoscaling,
and also improvements
in separatability.
These two features are
available in two GCP regions,
in US-central1 and Europe-west1.
Dataflow Shuffle is now
in general availability,
and the Streaming
Engine is in beta.
If you would like to try one
of these features or Dataflow
in general, please go to
cloud.google.com/dataflow
and you'll get all the
information you desire.
So with this, stay
tuned for the Q&A.
We'll be back in just a minute
after reviewing the questions
that were submitted.
I would be happy to answer
the questions you have.
Welcome back.
So we did get quite
a few questions here.
So let's go through them.
The first one was,
how do I start
using the Dataflow Shuffle?
If you remember from my demo,
I used the parameter that said,
experiments equals, shuffle
mode equals service.
That's all you need to do
to start using the Dataflow
Shuffle feature.
Incidentally, this is
exactly the same way
you would specify, with just
slightly different parameter
name, how would you specify the
use of the Streaming Engine?
In the Streaming
Engine's case, you
would say experiments equal
Streaming Engine equals
a particular value.
If you would like to know
the exact wording of these
parameters, just go to the link
I shared in the previous slide,
cloud.google.com/dataflow.
Go to our Docs.
And you'll see the parameters.
They are right there.
You don't have to
change your code.
You only have to
change or specify
a parameter in the
submission of the pipeline.
The second question
is about APIs.
Are there any
special APIs required
to use Shuffle and
Streaming Engine?
No special APIs are required.
You're still thinking in terms
of a direct or cyclical graph.
You write your
Dataflow pipelines
using either the Python or Java
SDK using the same commands,
same transforms that
you are used to.
Remember, the Shuffle
and Streaming Engine
will be used
anytime and when you
decide to use these
two components, anytime
you use a code group by
key or a group by key.
These are the two
operations which use
Shuffle and Streaming Engine.
The third question is about
the maximum size of data sets
that a Dataflow Shuffle
operation can support.
100 terabytes is
not the maximum.
We've seen customers doing
much more than 100 terabytes.
So, as I mentioned before,
the ceiling is actually
being increased every
month, every quarter as we
do improvements on the service.
Hopefully by this
time next year I'll
be able to add a
digit to this number.
Another question talks
about whether you
can use the Streaming Engine
without using Dataflow.
So today, the Streaming
Engine and Dataflow service
are kind of part of this--
of a larger offering.
It's currently not possible
to use the Streaming
Engine without Dataflow.
But it's an interesting
consideration.
Is the Streaming Engine free?
Do you have to pay for
the Streaming Engine?
The Streaming Engine does
generate billable units.
Actually both in the Shuffle
case and the Streaming Engine
case, the unit of billing
and the unit of usage
is the amount of bytes
you process and run
through these services.
So they scale very
linearly with the data
sets that you're
trying to process.
The feature is not free, but
it's very reasonably priced.
And you can get the pricing
information by going
to the Dataflow page,
cloud.google.com
/dataflow/pricing.
Another question talks
about stateful processing
with the Streaming Engine.
Can you do stateful processing
with the Streaming Engine?
So this is something
that I didn't have time
to touch upon in the
presentation in the webinar.
But Dataflow does
have a state API.
And the state API will actually
work with the Streaming Engine
where the state
will now be stored
not on the persistent
disks of your workers,
but on the back
end of our service.
So yes.
You can do stateful processing.
There's a state API for
streaming pipelines.
And the last question talks
about joining streaming data.
Specifically, can you
join streaming data
with master data?
So a use case like
that would be, you have
a stream of sales transactions.
And you have, like,
a lookup table
that converts from a
string value to an ID value
that you will then use
perhaps for storing in a data
warehouse.
The answer is it's pretty easy
to accomplish such a join.
In our terminology I would
recommend doing a side input.
Side inputs allow you
to define lookup tables,
so lookup data sets.
And as long as they
fit into memory
of a single worker, maybe a
gigabyte or several gigabytes,
you do have the leverage
of being able to define
different machine sizes.
So as long as your data
set is reasonably large,
not measured in terabytes,
perhaps gigabytes,
you can do a very, very fast
in-memory join of streaming
data with master data.
Now, if your data
set is large, you
should use the
streaming Shuffle that
is enabled by you specifying
the code group by key operation
in your pipeline.
And with this we
are good for today.
Thank you very much for
joining this webinar.
I enjoyed sharing more about
Cloud Dataflow with you.
Stay tuned for the next webinar,
Unlocking Data Analytics
and Machine Learning
with BigQuery ML.
[MUSIC PLAYING]